[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about the
power of being open we have Casey lye
joining us what's up hi thank you so
much for coming out happy to be here
thanks for having me super excited NIH's
Daz one of the greatest minds of our
time
yes so yes I appreciate the invitation
to be here yes this is very important
conversation we're about to have excited
to dive into depth view Casey's
background writer comedian the host of
the gate gate our gay power and happy
hour it's our half hour gay power half
hour podcast yeah and that links below
gay power half hour and us I've had like
150 episodes we've we've had we put out
about 140 episodes at this point we're
pushing really yeah it's really good and
it's podcast with one of my best friends
who is a drag queen and I am a comedian
and we both air our damage and our
friendship and our views on what is
going on in the world and I think you
know you don't think that I can meet a
gay comedian and a drag queen or the
people you want to hear opinions on on
the issues of the day but actually you
do yeah and so that's roaring hot and
then you know this is this is a really
important episode because this power of
being open is so crucial to talk about
I'm excited to get into that with you
you know you just started kind of
telling us a bit about kind of you know
you and your partner on the on the
podcast as well as you know give it give
this to us this we like to talk about
this state of humanity your kind of
synthesis on what's going on in our
world so you tell us what you're
thinking sure well I think that any gay
person would agree any gay person who
is out I think would agree that we all
grow up with a kind of with a with a
with a facade or behind a facade and I
think that everyone does that in a way
you know everyone kind of creates the
person they want to be but I think that
gay people are very aware of it because
we're kind of growing up in this dual
existence where there's the internal
person that we are and then the external
person that we present and those two
things can be very different I think
much more so than a lot of other people
because it's a matter of self protection
and preservation that would grow up with
that and so what I think is interesting
is when you start shedding it when you
start getting out of it you do realize
that every week I think it makes you
more hyper aware of the facade in
general you know and so like it kids
kind of my like superpower to be able to
see when someone is being real or it's
not being real because I know their
tells because I lived it you know and
I'm not an expert on I'm at an academic
expert by any means unlike things like
shame and stigma and the closet and
sexuality in general but I have lived
all these things and so my experience
meshed with the experience of all of
these people in my life who have had
similar experiences gives me I think a
pretty good perspective on how all of
that works
do you have gaydar we all have gaydar we
all gays have gaydar because what gaydar
is I love that question actually what
gaydar is is a way of figuring out
others in your tribe you know and you
had it had to develop very subtly you
know these modes of communication
so what gaydar is I mean of course there
are people who are kind of a bit more
like like fabulous you know and so as a
result they're easier to read you know
but people are always asking me oh it's
this person gay or is that person gay
and to me it's all about this lingering
eye contact between two men you can see
there's an eye contact thing that goes
on it happens on the street it's kind of
called like cruising but it really is
just like there's this like extra
second or so it's almost like
imperceptible to straights but like to
me that's what gaydar is and I used to
like really I used to be really
interested in in in like in that and
like if someone was hiding their
sexuality now I don't care as much
because you know I've come to learn that
sexuality is very much a person's own
thing and I also have come to believe
much more in the wide breadth of the
sexuality spectrum which I think
especially gay men struggled believing
for a long time because we were is
always just wishful thinking and I think
I mean sexuality is sexuality I believe
I really believe this I feel like
sexuality and the universe are the two
great unknowns two things that we know a
lot about but there are just some things
about it that are still completely
unexplained you know like nature versus
nurture is not a fair question because
there is you know and there are plenty
people on undecided that it's completely
innate ability born in who then you see
things that that that that you know fly
in the face of all of that research you
know it's absolutely true people you
know I mean women who I know women who
don't have him come out who don't come
out and didn't even realize that they
had attraction to women until they were
well into their lives you know and they
had families and kids and never even
thought about it and you know there is
there's plenty of trauma that goes into
a determination of one sexuality that
can you know and then there are people
who are just born gay as that you know
sorry for my legs like a see let's
unpack this asymmetry more because it is
so difficult to carry a facade and
because of cultural pressures and this
power of being open shatters that facade
so tell us about the asymmetry and then
shattering through yeah that's
interesting so I think from my personal
experience the overwhelming
intensity with which mmm hiding my
sexuality like the energy that went into
hiding my sexuality for so long was all
encompassing and I really think that it
kept me from using my brain in much more
productive ways you know because I was
seeking that I was constantly on edge
you know I was constantly on edge and
and it took me a long time to overcome
that feeling you know I didn't I grew up
in a way in which I just didn't trust
ever my own instincts because I knew
that my instincts could give away my
sexuality and it's not and I wasn't
raised incredibly by any means like
repressive or oppressive like state you
know I was raised Roman Catholic but not
like like very dogmatic you know and not
very like strict by any means but all of
those things creep in into you and but
just by growing up gay in society in
almost all societies is is you're being
told that you're wrong you're being told
that you're bad you're being told that
you're going to hell you're being told
that your life is going to be harder all
of these things so like and you're a
child you know I mean I mean I became
aware of my sexuality at puberty you
know so like 11 and 12 you know and so
you're already your hormones are raging
and then on top of that you have all of
this pressure from society telling you
that you are inherently wrong so it's a
lie I'm gonna keep my stuff in the
closet well never come out yeah that's
and that might work for you and that
might work for some but you know I mean
what it does for a lot of people
especially kids is it drives them to
contemplate suicide because that's the
easiest out you know and so and then and
that's why rates of suicide still to
this day for LGBT community is
staggeringly high because I'm its shame
its stigma and it's the pressures of
society you know and then you put them
on you see not only are you dealing with
those pressures you're dealing with your
own internalized hate of all of that so
it's a lot to deal with and it's
something that I didn't fully really
realize
and didn't like unpack the power of all
of that and its negative consequences
until recently and I'm also HIV positive
which added a whole nother layer of
shame a whole nother layer of stigma and
actually put me back into a closet in my
20s where I was just kind of like raring
to get out of the one that I had been in
for so long you know and I was out and
so when I became positive it just kind
of like put me down on this spiral of
like well what was all the work for
because now I'm just back in a worse
scenario and in this day and age if
you're HIV positive and you live in a
you know like I mean if you live in a
place where you have access to like
medication all that you are actually
physically going to be fine
and so the emotional toll is actually
one that can cause a lot more damage
because you you have now become in the
eyes of society the bad guy the bad
queer the queer that bears the
consequences of the sin and the sin is
the gay sex you know so so then I had to
deal with all of that and so I had to
like power through that and then it took
me a while to be open without that so
I'm also a comedian and I started doing
comedy in my mid-20s and I was
determined to be an out gay person from
the get-go not everyone makes that
determination I was determined to be I
didn't know how to do it any other way I
wanted to be open about who I was and
then I became positive I didn't know how
to make that funny you know so it took
me a while to do that but now I do and
it's hilarious but it's also what I
didn't realize was the process of coming
out as a gay hiv-positive man while it
added on layers of stigma coming from
people towards me it started to like it
allowed me to kind of shed the shame and
also build up this like armor against
the like stigmatization coming
at me and it has made me a lot stronger
as a performer but also as a person and
from what I do creatively which is very
personal like all of that has integrated
than to be being I think you know a
really at least having a really
interesting perspective on the way that
like the world is working you know
nothing can really I'm not scared of
what can take me down because I and I
think the point is because I'm so open
about Who I am
yep yep okay so let's go with this this
expression of self being able to be
maximally present with everyone so
enabling a social fabric that allows the
mat of the maximal presence of one's
true self
because like you said the rates of
depression or the ranks of suicide in
LGBTQ not cool
needs to be more stronger social fabric
of enabling people to be who they are
and then also you talk about how getting
through these these severe walls of
adversity at you found your greatest
treasures in life on the other side of
them that seems to be a reoccurring
theme with the guests that we feature
sure we talk about those well I think
it's it's so interesting to me to live
in this day and age and watch politics
unfold and because it's full of people
with deep dark secrets who are ambitious
narcissistic whatever enough to want to
climb the ranks of the political ladder
to be in charge of things you know power
is very alluring all that stuff but to
know that they're living this existence
where someone might find out that deep
dark secret and like to know that to be
wondering when and if that's going to
happen I mean currently we're watching
what's happening in Virginia with the
governor
had like a blackface picture come out
and then the lieutenant governor has
sexual assault allegations following him
now and then the Attorney General who
was the third in line has black face
pictures coming out and and like I'm
bringing this up because I like I find
that I found this whole new power of and
this whole new strength in in not
worrying what other people might know
about me you know and not worrying what
might come out about me or not being in
a crowd and wondering if someone is
thinking this about me or that about me
you know and it I'm just a minute I'm
just amazed at how many people we all
have secrets you know we all have have
have things but like I know how
corrupting those things can be on a mind
which is why I'm just watching like
politics full of all of these like
corrupted brains like seeking power and
we continue to just like vote for them
and and allow it to be it's all very
it's it's scary to me and staggering to
me because you know like it's
interesting way to put it because that's
in in in a sense that that can explain
some of the greatest traumas and
turmoils of our world is the this this
desire to be in control yeah of other
people rather than figuring out how to
get to the root of human and help humans
flourish from inside a short well it
allows your I mean and also like getting
through these things allows your empathy
levels to grow yes and because one when
you're not as concerned about what other
people are thinking about you you can
put more concern on like what's going on
with other people and also when you go
through hard things and you comment on
the other side of those hard things you
hopefully have an understanding of what
other people are going through and I
think all of that has been you know
these are all things that I've realized
in my work my Jane
through it all I your questions we're so
smart and well articulated that I don't
remember all of them so if your story is
so good that there's so many good
questions asked
let's take us take us to because you all
right you hit kind of the answers to
those two now take us to there are other
people that have these these adversities
that are so overwhelming and and then
you got hit with a second one which was
HIV positive now teach us about how you
you said you you're still able to stay
physically healthy yeah so teach us
about how to be able to stay physically
healthy in that regard and then and then
the preventative health care for that
oven and then after that teach us about
how for those that may be experiencing
similar emotional turmoil sure you can
break through that I thank you for
asking that because I think that guy
that kind of what gets lost in the the
idea that like HIV it's not something
that's killing people anymore is why
that is you know and it has to do with
the fact that the science is great and I
take you know I've been lucky you know I
was lucky to get it in a time when the
medication worked and it's been ten
years since I've been positive and I
started medication relatively soon after
finding out that I was and I have been
completely I mean I've been I've been
very healthy ever since I take care of
myself
for the most part you know I mean I eat
well and I exercise but I also like you
know do the other things that comics do
and drink and smoke and hang out you
know more than I should but I eat better
than most strict comics is you have to
stay fabulous I can't get smoked and
hang out - yeah we drink and smoke and
hang out we're talking like funny so far
I would beg to differ but after this we
should drink and smoke and hang out
there we go
yeah yeah I you know do all of that and
that I'm lucky other people have more
complications and it's still I'm not
saying that HIV is something that's
great and you should have but I am
saying that it is very different than
what it was and so you've physically the
medication is what keeps me alive then
there's also something because the
medication
it keeps the the HIV almost completely
at bay in your body and so what it does
do is it creates this thing in your body
we call it undetectable and it means
that you have an undetectable level of
the virus inside of you so like when
they draw your blood like there are
anybody's which means that they can see
that your that gets there but there is
no real sign of it to the point that I
can't transmit it so the virus gets so
subdued in your body and the levels are
so low in your blood and your semen that
you that I I mean the the research is is
is pretty conclusive that if you are
medicaid to the point of undetectable
you cannot transmit HIV then there's
this drug that people can now take who
are in I mean they're offering it to
people in high-risk groups of for
getting HIV
it's called prep Truvada I think is it's
marketed name they're starting to
actually market it I think was they
marketed on the superboss I'm like that
but you that's a pill a day we can take
preventive for preventive you know and
that is seemingly very effective as well
not a hundred percent but very effective
and so all of that is great and so like
we're working towards the you know
eradication of new transmissions and
hopefully the eradication of the
is period you know there is a more
cynical angle on on that that the drug
companies have figured out a way to get
all HIV and sexually stigmatized groups
on on a pill rather than getting a cure
sure sure cancers I think that's
interesting you know that's terrible and
that's it's a cynical way of looking at
it I hope not well interesting it's the
pharma Lobby wanting to get hooked on a
pill it's a cynical way of looking at it
but at the same time getting to the root
rather than a band-aid is most important
yeah well [ __ ] big pharma yeah I mean I
you know I mean it's you know Big Pharma
keeps me alive
you know I mean I and that's how I have
to I have to look at it and and and I do
like I'm I'm sympathetic to what Big
Pharma is capable of doing for for good
and for humanity this is the nuance
wrong you know maybe not saying that
maybe not Big Pharma know but like but
like [ __ ] big corporate industry that is
doing its best to keep people at bay and
make money off of their pain for sure
yeah but odds they're like just keeping
you along yeah I mean I can't you know
like I'm alive because of the pill that
I take that Gilead makes you know and
shout out to their engineers iliad ill
yeah I think that's my that's yeah
that's the one that's there for yeah and
so for sure but also like you know I
think it's pretty
I think it's nuts that there there
hasn't there isn't a cure for HIV after
all all of these years you know and I
think once they realized that they could
keep everyone alive and on medication it
probably became more incentive to do
that I mean that's the other part of it
I don't I think that their bottom line
is their their motivator and so you know
a bunch of non dead queers is uh who are
on their meds is a is a good thing for
them so that's one way to think about it
of course I'd miss my uncle's who got it
earlier in its stage well when we lost a
hole we lost generation and a half or
two generations of gay men of some of
the most interesting creative
intelligence I mean to list the minds
that we lost a child who should be on
the show today yeah I mean it's it's
it's still a great tragedy but it's
different now and it's better now and
and so a couple I mean a couple things
go from that I mean like what I'm
working on is again this D
stigmatization because I think what's
interesting is because it's so because
people are living and the disease is so
different less people are talking about
it because it's you know III think about
a two ways one you know it's it's a it's
still it's still a rough conversation
it's a sexually transmitted disease I
mean in the end that is the thing that
like makes it more stigmatized than
cancer you know like if a young person
gets cancer there's still shame in
sickness I mean that is a that is a
well-established thought you know
there's a well-established thought and
all that that like you know why that
exists but I you know I mean as I like
to say that sage or whatever I mean I
got a disease in my butt you know and
like that there's an added stigma that
comes along with that and you don't have
to talk about it because you don't look
like you're dying anymore you know I
mean like that was a thing like like
people were talking about AIDS because
people were like everyone was just dying
all of a sudden everyone was just
getting sick and dying and no one knew
why and then all of a sudden everyone
was and then all of a sudden it became
so big that that the whole world was
scared of it you know so it started to
have you had to start talking about it
and you couldn't avoid talking about it
and now you can avoid talking about it
I think is very harmful for a variety of
reasons where you know people are like
infections are still strong you know and
it's still going and it's still
happening get tested frequently yes
especially if you're sexually active and
be very open about what's happened yeah
and if you do find out that you're HIV
positive just know that you're gonna be
fine you know and just know that you're
only gonna be fine if you know that you
have it and you get treated yeah you
know and then you can transcend into a
whole new level of like consciousness
and understanding of the way that you
are and the way that the world works and
my uncle who is also a gay agent V+ man
and has been for years and lived well
past the time that he was supposed to
die and is still living to this day you
know he recently said something to me
about how out hiv-positive people out
gay it should be positive people are the
most open people in the world and you
know while that is hard to prove
empirically I do think that there are
somebody to be said for that because you
have overcome two different types of
very society scaring first adversity you
know like you you you have power through
and then what do you get like after that
like that's I think that's that's like
what do you have what's the point of
like of keeping up the facade after that
you know yeah like I don't I don't
you're you've you've already kind of
labeled yourself as something that
society is like skeptical of but then
you have a choice to either make that
powerful or to like retreat again and I
think that like for I think I think a
lot of people who've make the choice to
come out as as
to be open about their status then they
kind of start to transcend we find so
much of our life's most meaningful
treasures on the other side of the
traumas and transcending those and
getting through these walls of adversity
and this is a reoccurring theme and I'm
glad that you're pointing it out and
also you're pointing out the you know
the importance of science to help
prolong prolong life in the year of
again preventative health care being
open this is very important because if
you like you took it to the sphere of of
even all the way up to of what we're
experiencing with many people with with
greed and corruption and these
extractive economic principles like
rent-seeking and things that are
actually tremendously harming the middle
class and the lower Essen and so if if
people could get through some of those
vulnerabilities and be open about their
vulnerabilities and to be more inclusive
in many ways that we could prosper more
effectively I I agree you know and I and
I think I mean going back to kind of
like the title of like this episode or
which is like the power of being open I
think if you like looking at the the me2
movement the openness of that the
honesty and openness is a threat to the
power structure you know and you see
that I think most clearly recently with
the me2 movement because as you're
seeing there is there are very few
people in the established power
structure who are not terrified by the
me2 movement because they are for the
most part straight men and as a result
of that we have seen that straight men
no offense
have taken way too many liberties with
the power that they have had and so by
opening up about that and it's imposing
this direct threat to their power
through we're not going to take this
anymore and you don't have the
ability to exert that type of power on
us anymore there is this huge backlash
and the backlash is no more apparent
than the current President of the United
States who is is a very interesting
example of humanity to me because he he
lacks shame in a in a bad way he I don't
think he has his like shame like
receptors you know so like like he
there's definitely something very unique
about his brain you know in in that he
he doesn't feel that shame so it's like
a little bit of shame I guess is useful
when it keeps you from like just a lot
like okay you know the the shame of
being a shitty person you know of being
you know of like being a sexual harasser
and a Salter of being just an unabashed
user and abuser and liar you know I mean
that is what we see with this person and
and the and vote and and I mean I I hate
to be so political because I want this
to be for everyone but like he kind of
embodies this backlash against like
openness and transparency and like
acceptance of everyone in all things
because by it because if you do that
then again like like the power structure
that's been in place especially in this
country forever is a direct threat is
directly threatened by all of that so
I'm I'm III you know I so that's I mean
I think that's why it's so important for
people to [ __ ] stand up and be seen
you know to like to share their stories
and connect dot and to connect on these
things because my experience is
completely different from everyone
else's experience and but that doesn't
but by sharing this I feel like people
can relate on levels that you know have
nothing to do with HIV or gayness in
particular but with like you know like
with that adversity and overcoming that
adversity and
overcoming society's perceptions yeah on
the way things are supposed to be the
movement is so powerful and it it's it
just it's so interesting now seeing
people willing to put themselves on the
line to be vulnerable and to express
themselves where things used to be
bottled up right so that in itself is
power right yeah and that's kind of what
we're saying this power of being open
yeah and not having a facade is so
crucial it's like it's having a symmetry
in life because if you're if you're
symmetry in your and Nassim Taleb talks
about this a lot is that if your
symmetry in your in your private life
and your public life
yeah symmetrical you feel so much more
in balance and in harmony it feels so
good 100% and I think you know I mean
with what I'm doing is I mean it's I
wasn't thinking about it so much as
symmetry as much as full integration in
a way and they and and and I'm not and
I'm not sure that that's totally the
right thing that I need to be doing
either but it's where it's kind of the
work the way that it has been moving
where the you know the performance me
and private me there aren't a lot of
lines between them there's not a big
boundary between them and I and I I
think the problem with that is that like
then when you're putting yourself out
there performative lis like it is a and
whether you're accepted or rejected it
is a direct it feels very much at your
core you know it feels like it is you
the the real you that they're accepting
or rejecting and so there's not a lot of
safety in that but I don't know if it
just feels right for me to be the most
me that I can be like on stage and in
and in and and you know with while
writing yes to be true to thine own self
and that's what people want to see to I
mean that's what people want to feel and
you know I'm just I'm there's so much
negativity out there and comedy can be
really negative let's transition yeah
let's transition here because you are
able to Express
or life's journey this power of being
open through comedy through your writing
and other people do that as well what is
what would you say is your ethos of
comedy and then also what you see as
being this positive ethos that comedy
can bring to the light yeah you know i
mean--can it's there's a lot I mean
there's just so much to comedy in just
comics and when and and there's been a
lot of bad publicity with comedy of late
because of louis c.k and a lot of you
know there's there's a there's a dark
side to comedy in comics and that has to
do with the fact that it takes a certain
amount of damage to do what we do and I
think people certain comics synthesize
their damage in a way that it makes them
more open and it makes them more
empathetic and it makes them want to
bring happiness to other people and
there's others who synthesize it in a
way where that just makes them like
darker and and and odder and weirder and
and and and strange people and both is
fine as long as no one's [ __ ]
assaulting anyone else you know oh my
god fully fully supportive of all kinds
of comedy but you know there there are
some huge pieces of [ __ ] in the comedy
world and there are some of the best
people that I've ever met in my entire
life in the comedy world I think what I
do is like entertainment you know I mean
it's be I want people to feel good I
want people to feel good I want people
to be to to laugh at things that they
were that that were completely
unexpected
you know and I also want people to can I
kind of like connect with me and on on
things that are hard or bad or weird or
dark and then
release some of those things even if
it's just for a moment or not you know I
I'm not a dark even though my subject
matter can be dark I'm not a dark comic
you know like and that and I think there
that's a bit that's been a interesting
development for me because I think I got
as a young comic I got labeled dirty and
dark because of my subject matter which
was you know I just I think like if
you're gonna talk about sex in any form
I'm gonna be you're gonna be deemed too
dirty comic I think you know and I
definitely push the boundaries of that
as a younger comic and sometimes I still
do I don't mind dirtiness if it's funny
I think that there's like you know there
you're poking the taboos and I think
that that's good but I like to think of
myself as you know I think I'm a smart
comic I think I take issues that people
don't always want to talk about and I
find ways to make them funny and I find
ways to make them light you know and I
nothing makes me happier than watching
people laugh at something that they know
they shouldn't be laughing at they
thought that they shouldn't be laughing
at you know that they think they
shouldn't be laughing at and it's super
fun because I'm good at it you know and
I'm likeable I'm a good face for gay
hiv-positive comedy you know because I'm
you know I am I'm I'm I'm not I'm over
the pain part of it you know and that's
I think something else that happens with
comedy is people use it
comedians use it as catharsis and they
use it as therapy and I'm like there's
actual therapy use actual therapy you
know and because what is uncomfortable
to watch on stage is someone still going
through the the cauldron of pain or
issues surrounding whatever it is
because then it's because then it can
still be sad or weird and I'm not saying
people shouldn't do that you need to be
able to do that to get to the to the
next level but like
don't owe it part of me as er just don't
always synthesize your pain onstage in a
comedy club but why don't you know I
mean then then then there's a whole I
mean there's a big whole question of
like what is comedy
what is stand-up you know what does it
have to be and I still think that that
old equation of tragedy plus time equals
comedy still kind of exists and it's
real because I think in the end like
there's great performance about pain
there's great performance about you know
all of that stuff but it's not always
comedy and sometimes it gets billed as
such but maybe I'm a purist I don't know
I'm Reza nating what the way that you're
you're talking about this because I
think you know now that we've been
hosting more and more comedians I think
it's becoming more and more clear that
there are in very there's cool lessons
to explore as a comedian with your time
with an audience and you can explore
things like poking fun at the way that
this is the 3,000 people at Davos were
avoiding their taxes and and we're
talking about philanthropy the entire
time right and I think if you do that
then you can explore you can awaken
people yeah with that then that can be a
profound way to use comedy but when
you're when you're doing this thing they
call it punching down where you're you
where you're you know you're actually
potentially hurting people and making
people you know feel worse and that that
and some people can laugh at that yeah
but so so anyway how do you feel about
about what I just said you know like if
you are a comic if you're if you're if
if you're listening and you want to get
into comedy and you have all these
really great jokes about trans people
you can consider maybe not doing them
you know because
unless it's about how great and
interesting and how how good of a story
it must be to be born into a different
gender than you are and overcoming all
of that because like like in fact if
you're just gonna cut AK them then
you're just a Tesla or you're gonna
you'd be like I don't get it or whatever
it's like blah blah blah I make fun of
bathrooms and all that stuff you are you
are attacking one of the more
marginalized groups in our society and
if that makes you feel good laughing at
that
then check why that does why because
it's easy you know it's it's easy and
you know you might get a group of a big
group of people in on your side with
that but does it is it doing anything
for you for your solar for the [ __ ]
society at best no it's not and I think
you you know for me the I can get
negative I'm not saying I'm there's just
like super like happy everyone's great
yeah I can get negative about the
political power structure for sure and I
have very harsh things to say about
specific people and I have some
unpolitical II correct things to say
about people and I will push those
boundaries as well as I see fit if I'm
making an argument if I can justify it
with an argument in my brain I mean an
example is I I call Sarah Huckabee
Sanders a fat ugly Nazi in my act and
that is something that gets a rise out
of liberals in not a good way because it
is attacking a woman for the way that
she looks and I am asking the question
of if it's okay because it's like you
know people you'll call this person a
Nazi but you won't call her fat like
what like why or you you want me to you
say it's okay to punch this person
because there are Nazi but you can't
criticize them for the way they look and
I'm not saying that I have this answer
to it but I'm more opposing the question
of like is it okay to do that how do we
fight in this way
and also every word that she's uh Turing
professionally in defense of Donald
Trump is in my mind an attack on women
so so so when it comes to like this
question this is the question is like is
I'm not I'm not punching down you know
but because she's a woman
a you know historically marginalized
figure in our society especially a woman
in power who is very easily attacked for
their appearance in whether they look
regardless at political perspective am I
am i punching up or am I just a my
punching sideways you know I will not
say that the press secretary of Donald
Trump is someone who is below me you
know that I'm punching down for but it's
I just it's to me those are like
interesting questions within comedy of
what's okay or not and I don't know if
actor yeah I mean that's I mean that's I
mean that I
she is loathsome to me you know but I
also don't want to be doing a joke that
hurts other women because of what it is
at its core I don't believe that that's
true you know we have to be careful
because on the show we really we push to
never dehumanize ever absolutely and so
the we just we have to no matter what
even if it is someone that have finds
themselves in a position where they are
doing some sort of of malevolence that
like what where and why can't we do
human eyes the the nonhumans the ones
that are lacking in that human spirit
that we're all trying to hang on to and
go forward I don't for a minute tell me
that there are nonhumans among us
there's something about the human spirit
that we need to latch on and there's
some they're not they're just not humans
what would you say dehumanize Sarah not
human may I may I finish the statement
this was this was going to go ahead
direction so it's very important as we
aim to not
dehumanize anybody because we are doing
our best to get behind their eyes and a
see which environmental stimuli led them
to have the belief system sure that they
do today and when we do that process we
are identifying the sort of weirder
potentially more parasitic styles of
environment that people can be exposed
to where their ethics don't evolve fast
ensure and so so it's a process of
learning the structural malevolence as
in parasites in and violence's the
violence's that prevent people from
ethically evolving that prevent them
from maximally flourishing yeah that is
why we do that process
and at the same time however we solve
like you're saying potentially through
comedy or through this issue I think it
requires a big big degree of empathy a
big dose of humility and a big dose of
being this better person that I think if
we can set that as an example yeah you
know and I think I mean I I think you
know to be very Buddhist about it like
to to not have these two to get rid of
these negative thoughts and to not air
these negative thoughts into to get to a
point where you're not having like where
I see again Sarah Hagen centers or that
where I see Sarah how can be Sanders or
I see Donald Trump and I don't hate them
you know that hate which I do have I
absolutely have hate for them for what
they stand for because they stand
against what I see as like a path of
truth and justice and righteousness you
know I had their their impediments to
that but I see them as human for sure
you know and and and actually was
interesting you said the dehumanization
part because you know I think you call
someone a Nazi in this day and age is
almost to try to it's almost as it's
almost to dehumanize them you know and
and tis also to set them up for for
attack and violence because Nazis as a
whole or one of the most loathsome yes
human creatures who have ever existed
you know and must be also careful
because then that can also cause further
polarization 100
the polarization is in the right you
lose you lose you lose the ability to
persuade someone if you start by you by
condiments but he can't persuade
retailers I agree I agree she is not
seven she has proved proved herself time
and time again to be set in her ways and
not see whatever swayed and when it
comes down to it she thinks I'm going to
hell for who I am you know I mean that
and so it's like what where are we where
are we supposed to start
I had a common ground this then this may
be an interesting common ground Asst I
very much so identify myself as a free
thinker a maverick independent no labels
labels and so by when I when I kind of
am able to approach people who may be on
you know a far side of this belief
spectrum that that I come in with the
big degree of humility and a big degree
of asking lots of questions and getting
to know them building rapport with them
door and then I slowly introduce them to
how other people feel of your reality
and then they go sometimes they go hmm
and then when they do that that's the
first step towards empathy with your
other people and then that right there
can get people on these far polar
spectrums to come one step more towards
a place of empathizing and I and I agree
with that and I actually I am not I'm
not I mean I don't know how I've sounded
in this but I'm not set in my ways I'm
not set in my like political ideologies
either I'm I'm I'm very open and I'm
very open to conversation I would love
to sit down and have conversation with
people who see the world differently and
I do do that but from like from from the
the way in which things and reality and
truth being manipulated at the highest
levels of our power structure you you
their intentions are so bad it feels
like their intentions are so bad that
I'm not sure how they can ever see my
point of view they live in a reality
that is completely that in one in which
that
in which I am the enemy and so it's hard
to I don't see them as the enemy unless
of course it does come out that they
have been manipulated or manipulated
things because of like a foreign power
then that's like then that's straight-up
enemy but let me do our best because I
have a strong feeling that the way that
we have plans to produce really powerful
media that I think we can get to a point
where the hate is going to set there's
gonna be an uprising of love and you
know and I and I mean this goes back
it's just it's a open communication
being or there's power and open
communication and I love the idea of
like the public intellectual being
brought back into the sphere because
that has been lost and been replaced
with you know like the the influencer
you know and the influencer is could not
presenting reality yeah well I'm here to
tell the both of you that they're gonna
kill you and I'm not here to agree with
those statements anyway okay I mean
would you [ __ ] love this love that
they hate and they're gonna kill you
yeah I just wanted to let you know that
you know I mean in that that you know I
mean I can't watch The Handmaid's Tale
and not like have this [ __ ] I gotta
get a gun like you thought process but
that is me I you know I'm not I'm I'm
very I'm I do not believe that our
society is just going to work itself out
I don't I believe this is the the weird
part of history like the America you
know the last couple hundred years of
America have been the blip in society
you know normally it's much more
devastating you know normally it's much
more driven by pure self-interest and
and and not saying that America hasn't
been for the last hundred years but I
mean like if we've grew up in a time of
feeling like things we're gonna work out
you know that and that's very unique to
human history and I and I think that we
have to fight
the dark forces that have aligned to
create our current society which is one
that is based on on closed mindedness
and not facts and not and not love you
know I mean it's crazy it's it is the
this current political climate has put
my family not my immediate family with
my extended family at odds and you know
we used to be able to like not dwell too
deeply but things have become so intense
and so polarized that the love has been
replaced by fear and hate and I'm
willing to have conversations about it
but I'm not willing to have [ __ ]
this is the other thing I'm this is this
is the other problem on the the other
problem with this is that start the flip
side of everything that I've been saying
about I don't have time to [ __ ]
anymore I don't have time to pretend III
if you don't want to have a real
conversation like I what we it our
interaction will be quick you know and
if someone wants to have a real
conversation about something about
something that will quickly become about
everything then [ __ ] call me up and
we'll have that conversation and I think
that the strategy that we take when we
aim to have this Dumont's discourse is
so important when when we're coming in
with a with with with this like Ron says
with this lead pipe and we know we want
to strike right that's a huge problem
right but when we come in more with hey
I want to ask you some questions about
your life and who you are how did you
even get here and we learn about them
they see we're interested we build
rapport and then we and then we see how
much you know that they open up and then
we're able to potentially explain some
of the life circumstances we've come
from and how we can bridge this gap and
that is not only between the political
ideologies but then that goes even
further to people around the world a lot
of people don't realize what life is
like when you still have to walk with a
jerrican to a well and get water when
people don't realize what it's like to
live in
more of an authoritarian country oh
absolutely and so when when we go
through these processes of learning oh
and behind other people's eyes and this
is the style of media that we produce
that we're aiming to produce that will
bind people together as again if a big
vaccine to all human ignorant is big
history deep time when you snap yourself
out of this 10 30 50 year lifetime and
you start looking at how civilization
was built by a hundred billion humans
before us right that gains a sense of
unity the Union a unity an empathy to
how we all came here with plants and
animals alike and that's how I think
boom that's a really good way to get
people to come together no I I agree 100
but what but what you can't have a
conversation with this someone who
doesn't believe a thing exists in the
first place you know and I think that
that is what we are struggling with is
there are a lot of people I mean there
are a lot of people there are a lot
people who don't believe that I have the
right to exist the way that I want to
exist and I don't know you know I and
then 100 percent it's about showing them
that that that's not the right way and
that's not and that's not real but it is
not something that I think our social
media structure and our entertainment
structure is capable of dealing with I
think that you find the facts that suit
your view and then you get deeper
ingrained and like you know I mean
there's that I I think the things that
I'm interested in is these people who
have been in hate groups in various
times of their life and then have come
out of those agree those are those
people are fascinating fascinating that
you need to give him the biggest
megaphone what and what that's exactly I
was gonna say these are the people who
know how to get out of it and they know
the trap that it is
but instead of those people being
president united states we have a white
nationalist sympathizer I'm not saying
he is one or not but this goes back to
briefly the governor of Virginia who I
just want to like touch them again
because I'm really interested in this
story and and then I have a couple quick
questions it kind of looks like he's
gonna stay the governor when everyone
was saying he's gonna be get pushed out
and that's because below him were two
other people who have issues in their
own right and so it's just like oh [ __ ]
it's a Democratic Party you stood there
but the only way that this can work out
in a productive manner is if he's
allowed the room to once all the the
once once things calm down a little bit
because you know what he did is in
defensively racist but what does he do
how does he how does the question how
does how does he use what he did as a
way to teach the state and America and
the rest of society because all eyes are
gonna be him unlike redeeming yourself
from that redemption is not something
that we have yet figured out how to deal
with in all of this time of the the me2
movement and the racist movement and the
politically correct movement is there
room for redemption there absolutely is
room for redemption and we have to let
it happen and I know that an argument
that I've been hearing and I've totally
sympathized with from the from
african-americans is a black net would
not be given the the the time or the the
chance to redeem himself in that way in
the society and that is true but this is
the reality of the situation now and if
we can't allow people to give their
honest thought process on the reduction
Ralph Northam has [ __ ] it up because
he has lied about he said he did was in
the picture that instead he wasn't in
the picture he said it was a different
time in all that stuff but you know what
that's that's that's human self defense
mechanisms coming out improperly is I
mean he's the governor sure he should be
held to a higher standard
sure but the
guy below him it has two allegations of
sexual assault so and the guy below him
has an allegation of blackface seems to
me like a lot of people in this country
in the 80s and 90s and Beyond were
painting their face black and now
they're hoping those pictures won't come
out what if instead of condemning all of
them for actions that they did 20 years
ago we use this as a way of stimulating
conversation of why people were doing
that why they thought it was okay and
why they don't have those feelings
anymore and if they do still have those
feelings how we can boast are overcoming
and unwrapping and unraveling those
feelings it's about being open about it
because the shame of the like like I
hate to be so I'm not gonna be so I'm
not gonna it's not so simplistic as to
say everyone is racist but everyone has
these inherent biases that we were
raised in the society if you're a white
person who was raised in America you
have racism ingrained in you you have it
ingrained in you and and it is shameful
to know that you are and so of course
you're gonna say no I'm not racist but
to if our leaders can start rather than
beating us over the head with race vidiq
baiting or rather than being completely
whitewashed from the scene you know we
can actually use them as examples of
people in the society who hopefully want
to do good things because they are
running to be public servants you know
if we can use them and their
transgressions as examples of how we can
move beyond it then we have something
because otherwise we're just going to be
stuck in this ever never-ending cycle
this and also this like like you know
French revolutionary cycle of where if
you're not pure enough from the
beginning and till the end then your
head comes off you know and and that and
and and and I'm not defending Ralph
Northam but I'm defending the idea of
redemption as as we need it in our
society it needs to happen because we're
all criminal yes yeah yep in one
capacity or another and from one
perspective of another we're all
criminals
you're you're you're touching on what I
think is one of the most important
conversations to have today which is the
path to redemption
everyone has very weird and scary and
hard to process baggage and trauma and
mistakes and if we can create a culture
of vulnerability the power of being open
and being like hey my ethics have
evolved yes if we can start making that
like hashtag ethics evolved or evolution
of ethics yeah whatever it may be that
if we can make that happen I think that
is that is the power that we can walk
around with okay the couple questions on
the way I'm yeah we talked Redemption
and ethics evolving that was really good
and and we got to figure that out what
that path is agreed what is a core
driving principle of your life a core
driving principle of my life I mean it's
yeah to beat a dead horse here but I
mean it's at this point it's it's
honesty it has not been the driving
principle for so much of my life
and when you're lying about such a core
thing of you for so long little white
lies start to kind of you just they
don't really matter you know to you it's
like who cares you know if you lie about
one one little thing because like so so
I it took me a while to like to to
realize the power that that being an
honest person you know had and I I just
think at this point you know that and
and I see and I mean empathy empathy and
honesty are the two core driving
principles at this point in my life
yeah and then do you think we're in a
simulation I would hope a simulation
wouldn't be so racist
I honestly that's like I've always
thought it's like like I mean I lot of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah this first if this
is simulated and then boy you know like
like I'll tell you who doesn't think
we're in a simulation [ __ ] like the
the oppressed you know it's easy to talk
about if we're in this
you know from from Silicon Valley area
you know oh yeah that's not snow but but
like the downtrodden and the beaten and
the oppressed in the and you know that's
not a that's not a simulation you know
well we have to learn if such is the
case we need to learn how to play this
game it's a simulation it's it's we do
have some control of over it if there is
stuff set up for us and it's it's
simulated reality there has to be it
can't work without us so we have to just
play the [ __ ] game yeah I mean I'm
well I believe more I honestly I don't
believe in this like matrix T type
simulation I believe more in a in a in a
this is where the the metaphysical and
the spirituality come into it - I
there's no knowing what we are and why
we are it and it goes back to what I was
saying about sexuality being as
interesting and mysterious as as the
universe because it's like at its core
like you can answer all these questions
but you can't get to the core it core
thing of why why it exists why it is and
the ontology yeah being a being and also
it's like you know like you know
sexuality at its core is for
reproduction but then what happens after
that why does why does same-sex
attraction exist and all of that all of
that why you know all of that so
blurring of the blurring the blurring is
very very interesting to me and I think
it's it's one line one last yeah Anna
it's just that I think people sometimes
fall again to this trap of time being
just their lifetime when you look at it
in a big history deep time perspective
you realize evolution is still happening
so the neurodiversity in this bodily
diversity that is evolving is going in
wherever it's going
yeah and so for us to just be like oh
this is what it's like it's like
nananana note did wherever we got to be
open to evolution we've got to be open
to evolution but I think what happens as
we're open to evolution is that what we
have to be open to which is not which
humans are not going to be capable of
leaving him leaving this human existence
behind you know because I mean from from
my understanding like the best guests on
why we haven't figured out who and what
extraterrestrials or alien civilizations
are it's because they've gone into the
data realm you know and so they are
existing in that type of that they exist
in the realm beyond the human the the
physical being the mole Taipa you know
and that and that is you know
fascinating but it's not something that
[ __ ] you know Karen and Indiana is
gonna be like super jazzed I'm figuring
figuring out you know and I was you to
Karen pence as an example okay um so I
got you I just I and I'm psyched about
it and that's not one that I want you I
but you know I'm I'm I'm I'm recently
getting in to Buddhism as an
understanding I must call myself a
Buddhist by any means but I'm just like
yeah and I I the the idea of like the
canned a candle being lit like lighting
it let you a flame and then passing the
flame on through candles while it's the
same flame it's a completely different
thing that like the the flame on the
candle down here while it has the same
complete origin and started in the same
exact way it's a completely different
thing and I think that's I'm very
interested in how in in that and and I
and I I would love to believe that you
know when the physical body is done then
something something that at its core was
the same but is it completely doing
don't stop believin case yeah I mean the
way it is but what's great is when he
don't show we've argue like you
don't know I know when you did you don't
doubt nobody dies there's no yeah get
over it yeah you have your whether you
like it or not if you had your way we
would bust up the drug companies and I'd
already because this machine would
already be gone I do have I weigh I'm
doing the best I can don't worry about
it I'm gonna be fine I think Casey let
me know Casey was the first one that
pointed out on the simulation question
that the people that are experiencing
the greatest difficulties in life not
having the basic needs met are
definitely not contemplating things like
are we in a simulation yeah they're
trying to do water in him yeah and yeah
so that was that was true voz extremely
interesting um okay last question yeah
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world
oh the male physical form ah I I am you
know the most beautiful thing in the
world that's such an interesting
question cuz it's it's hard for me I can
get overwhelmed by like the littlest
things
honestly if laying in grass and looking
at little bugs mmm is maybe the most
beautiful bugs are the most beautiful
thing if you know they're not if you
know like I'm you know I'm scared of
little creepy crawly things but if you
actually look at like the tiny little
insect and you see it and you're just
like the it's in the intricate nature
and the beauty of a ladybug you know
it's so crazy to me just the way their
existence yeah and their existence can
be gone like that you know and i think
you know i'm i'm pretty i get pretty
overwhelmed with those little those
little things I'm not gonna say that I
don't believe in some sort of higher
power or spiritual being because the
connect the connectedness that I can
feel I can feel a connection with animal
I can feel connections with insects it's
like and this isn't even from like a I
do mushrooms point of view like I can
like really they've helped me get to
that point I think but
they're really old they're really old
creatures yeah yeah it's just a night
really diverse ly different than humans
oh yeah I mean it's I mean they're
they're ant I mean it's in a whole
another alien so again so light that
they can hang like upside down and walk
upside down they can fly with the waves
just I don't even know a lot about I
don't and I'm this I didn't even this is
not something I even was like thinking
about all the time but like if I really
have to think about it it's just like I
mean I can I you know like a sunset is
what made me fall in love with
California you know like I mean it's
just it's I mean I'm just so happy I
think I had the most beautiful thing in
the world is existence yeah you know it
really is and it's and it's and and and
why it is because it's so it's so it's
it's complex and there's and and and but
also you can see it's dichotomous
because it's so bad in so many ways but
when it's good that's the thing that
fills me with the most amount of joy
yeah and that's I mean that's that gets
the answer into the clip yes yes and
shout out to our man Michelangelo for
that Statue of David oh boy oh boy
alright that is hot I mean yeah I mean
he really it really is the the desire
the the physical Amahle physical form
and I mean this is we this is a
different conversation but the JJ's nice
to know before I mean like and I think
like the body the physical form in which
attracts you is that you know and all of
us like those delicious nuanced but the
other thing is it's like you know I mean
I want masculinity in itself it's not
inherently bad and and you know
masculinity is under attack in a lot of
ways and and I love masculinity you know
I I'm attracted to masculinity so that's
made me think about about just you know
the way the way in which we talk about
and perceive certain things because
toxic masculinity is a big problem but
masculinity is like like you know sexy
so you know but what does it mean what
what does it mean to be one and
and and or the other and so for next
that's a completely different yeah for
the one I really want to dove in we will
we see our genitalia for next show Jim
Morrison I was Jim Morrison said that
back in the 60s that you know the before
is I love that that's funny
ACK Casey thank you so thank you so much
thank you super fun the show yeah this
has been a block thank you thank you
greatly appreciate you so much thank you
for teaching us about the power of being
open there's a lot to take from that
shattering through those adversities
being fully open having that loving
heart centric energy around the world
guys thank you so much for tuning and we
greatly appreciate you so so much do let
us know your thoughts in the comments
below let's build up that community
check out Casey's links below as well
and go check out the the gay power half
hour podcast also a be practice this
power of open inspire other people in
your communities to practice the power
of open your friends your family on
social media let's get to that stage
everyone and support local artists and
entrepreneurs comedians support your
local peeps that are really going hard
on building their dreams in the world
support them shout out to Ron thank you
for producing and directing and everyone
go and manifest your dreams into the
world we love you so much and we will
see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]